ce jeudi matin Nathan et ses parents ont
trouvé leur véhicule les quatre pneus
dégonflés j'étais à complètement à plat
il doit aller à gonfler à deux barres 3
donc faut faire l'effort quoi au total
dans toute la ville de Meudon et en une
seule nuit une soixantaine de SUV ont
été ciblés les auteurs se surnomme les
dégonfleurs de pneus contactés par mail
l'un des portes paroles nous explique
ces objectifs si rien qu'une seule
personne n'achète pas de SUV grâce à
notre action alors nous aurons gagné une
pratique qui toutefois peut être punie
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
d'un an de prison et 15000 euros
d'amende je le dis parce que ils ont ils
devaient venir ils ont demandé à mon
équipe où était ma voiture non je vais
vous dire la vérité je les aime beaucoup
ah voilà c'est des pompiers de sa
voiture sur la vie de ma mère ce sera
les derniers pneus qui vont dégonfler
juste parce qu'il paraît qu'il cherche
ma voiture sur ma vie c'est vrai c'est
pas une balle ils ont demandé à mes
équipes ont été ma voiture aujourd'hui
ok je les aime bien quand il dégonfle
les pneus Géraldine super
c'est génial ils sont super je les adore
je les ai défendu sur la tête de mort en
plus je vous dis j'ai toujours des gars
qui tournent autour de ma voisine ils
vont m'appeler ils vont me le dire mais
est-ce que les gars pour vraiment est-ce
que les gars pensent vraiment que vos
équipes vont dire oui oui elle est garée
dans cette rue peut-être et j'ai donné
et sachez qu'ils ont demandé à mes
équipes j'ai donné l'adresse de
Géraldine maillet voilà
donc voilà donc
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y en a qui
comprennent ça par gilbertez non même
pas toi
je suis pour des sanctions exemplaires
parce que c'est ultra dangereux ils
peuvent aussi de quelqu'un qui doit
partir en urgence à l'hôpital qui n'a
pas le temps parce qu'ils mettent des
petites étiquettes on a dégonflé votre
voiture mais parfois il pleut
l'étiquette elle tombe on n'a pas le
temps de la lire c'est hyper dangereux
franchement j'espère qu'ils seront
interceptés arrêtés et qui seront
condamnés pour mise en danger de la vie
dit la vérité bien sûr il y a un mec un
peu nerveux qui les voit ça va est-ce
qu'on leur dégonfler non mais je le sais
voilà moi je suis moi je suis pas de ce
type là mais un autre gars j'ai des
copains un autre gars tout ça je vous le
dis c'est vrai je vous dis ça va mal se
terminer pour eux ça me fait de la peine
parce que ça parle à mon sentiment et il
paraît qu'ils sont sympathique en plus
au téléphone et tout mais après ça peut
partir en cacahuète que je leur propose
de faire c'est d'aller devant les
paquebots devant les ferries
un paquebot Karine c'est un million
allez [ __ ] le bordel devant les faire
les meufs qui vont dans les faits la
pollution qui font ça et pourquoi ils
vont
[Applaudissements]
dans le port des gonflés des avions dans
les aéros les aéroports
c'est pas de ma faute parce que toi tu
dis ça parce que tu prends jamais
l'avion
non mais attends va manger des ravioles
il nous fait pas chier
très faible
c'est bon quand tu es mon seul ami si tu
passes avant non mais c'est vrai non
mais c'est un super il y en a pas un qui
dit oui personne
ton père
à l'hôpital c'est que c'est d'une
connerie tu freines tu tapes le tu peux
pas t'arrêter tu fonces dans une voiture
c'est d'une connerie réalise pas la
connerie en plus d'être SUV Electric qui
consomme pas j'en suis sûr tu veux
parler de la peau non il est pas
électrique de tiens pas du tout hein
c'est sûr que ça se trouve ils peuvent
dégonfler et comment ils vont savoir un
problème avec ta voiture toi moi je
prends le métro
le métro c'est pas quand on a un
chauffeur devant et qu'on a à l'arrière
est-ce que tu viens de me faire chier
que tes conneries il a deux minutes je
vais pas te lâcher t'inquiète pas ce
qu'ils font en fait le problème de ces
gens c'est qu'au lieu d'unir et de
Federer à travers des idées fortes ils
expriment une jalousie pathétique en se
cachant derrière des pseudos attention
écologiques qui servent à rien et au
lieu de s'attaquer au SUV des gens des
particuliers qui bossent pour s'acheter
ses voitures je sais pas attaquez-vous à
des grandes marques qui polluent parce
que j'aimerais bien voir si ces gens
sont 100 % irréprochables eux-mêmes sur
l'écologie j'en suis pas sûr ça sert à
rien
sans bébé oui alors mon cœur surtout
parce que là c'est un sujet que je
connais moi les voitures surtout que ces
gens-là qui sont des imbécis
malheureusement ça t'inquiète un
problème qui ne connaissent pas puisque
il faut quand même qu'ils sachent que la
plupart des voitures des petites
voitures qui voient des vieilles
voitures qui sont pas des SUV beaucoup
plus c'est qu'un 4x4 aucune voiture
aujourd'hui électrique qui a 4 ou 5
batteries aujourd'hui et beaucoup plus
polluante qu'une voiture à essence les
batteries aujourd'hui on les prend c'est
bourré de lithium de produits
dégueulasse on ne sait pas quoi en faire
on les enterre ça pollue la terre c'est
le scandale de demain dans 20 ans le
diesel gate et les batteries gate et les
voitures électriques pour l'instant
c'est une solution qui est très mauvaise
ça commence à sortir partout donc un SUV
aujourd'hui pollue beaucoup moins qu'une
vieille BM des années 80
[Applaudissements]